ANDREW HOUCK: Having a tag
like the Jacobus Fellowship
is something that
really helps her
get recognition outside of
the Princeton community,
so that she can really achieve
her goals over her career.
NEEREJA SUNDARESAN: My
name is Neereja Sundaresan.
I am a graduate student in
the electrical engineering
department and my research is
using superconducting circuits
to study many-body
quantum optics.
ANDREW HOUCK: Neereja is
an exceptional student.
She -- everybody in lab
calls her rabbit foot.
She's just seems
to get experiments
to work that seem really
challenging and difficult.
And so I mean, I feel like
I've known her since she
was a sophomore in college.
She came and worked in
my lab over the summer.
And even in eight weeks as a
summer intern, as a sophomore,
you could give her
a problem, and she
would come back with really nice
solutions that worked really
well.
Since she started as a graduate
student, every experiment she's
been given, she just
keeps plugging away
and gets things that seem
difficult, challenging,
impossible to work.
NEEREJA SUNDARESAN:
So we take a piece
of sapphire, which
looks very clear,
and we take it
into the clean room
and we deposit on top of it
a very thin layer of niobium.
And so when it goes down inside
our fridge to 10 millikelvin
or below its
critical temperature,
it actually superconducts.
So there's no loss.
So you can imagine that if you
have a very, very long wire --
just any wire that you
might see in this room --
and you send in a
very weak signal,
that wire itself is lossy, so
by the time you get to the end,
it's probably -- it's gone.
And you're just having
a bunch of noise.
But if this is
superconducting, whatever
you put in at the beginning
will be there at the end.
So you can think of it
as not having any loss.
And so what this
means is that you
can design different
types of circuits
where loss is very,
very controlled.
ANDREW HOUCK: A really
excellent student
is one who can start
off in a direction
but keep their eyes
open, and really
keep thinking about what's
going on and figure out,
when is it more fruitful
to change direction?
When is it more fruitful
to do this instead of that?
NEEREJA SUNDARESAN:
We understand
a lot of things about light.
And we understand a lot
of things about photons.
But we don't
understand everything.
There's a lot out
there that people just
don't understand yet.
It's something that will come
in the future, I have no doubt.
But it's by doing
experiments and doing
careful theoretical
analysis that we
understand how photons behave
in different environments.
Understanding them
and how they behave,
and getting them
to behave the way
you want to is a really
exciting area of science.
And so that's what
I'm interested in.